at what point has it ever been indicated
that the show is just quote flashy
lights with no substance in fact pretty
much everything we've heard so far
indicates the opposite moving away from
giant flashy beam struggles and
transformations to more grounded martial
arts action is already the opposite of
flashy lights not to mention it is very
clear that the show is the most
interested Toriyama has been in Dragon
Ball since well since the original
series before with Battle of Gods Dragon
Ball super and even Dragon Ball super
Broly and superhero yama's contributions
to stories have been minimal at best but
with da he is hands on like little we've
seen before not just in terms of
literally writing out episodes but also
going so far as to look over animation
cuts themselves it's honestly unheard of
for him I totally get that people were
expecting a continuation of super but
this existing doesn't mean that we won't
ever get that one thing that I'm certain
of is that there are way too many folks
out there saying it's going to be bad
without enough information to make that
very call